would you ever leave the state of
california if it got any worse
it's it's tough uh it's it's something
that has actually been
uh probably the biggest issue in our
family at home
is i am so frustrated with california
and it's why i'm running because
california is
such a great and beautiful place the
weather is so beautiful
only seven percent of the world has the
mediterranean climate where i live i've
got the mediterranean climate
uh and so many things i love about
california but
uh they're the things that i hate about
california seeing people die on the
streets the housing on affordability the
regulation
how long it takes me to get a building
permit for a ceiling fan it takes me
eight weeks
to permit a ceiling fan because oh well
staff cuts and
the fire department's coming over to my
house going weeks for a ceiling fan
i got the fire department coming over
kevin we've got
we've got the fire department spoke to
the firepoint we've got
millions of dollars ready to build a new
fire station but we can't get the
authorization to do it
meanwhile our response times are going
down and californians are suffering
it's all of the agencies throughout our
state that are suffering
and that's what's so sad is the
californian aggregate
knows that there are problems we just
need a stronger leader but yeah
we've look i i'm a big proponent of
in our family of saying look the
taxation
the lack of representation we get is a
driver to move to the beach in florida
to move to texas and and uh start a new
company
or a large media business in texas or
south florida or whatever
uh they would welcome you with open arms
here's your space here are your permits
you're operating right away
it's the opposite it's the opposite in
california and so there's so many things
that drive me out now lauren my wife
doesn't want to leave because of friends
and family it makes sense
yeah it makes sense so it is
california's problems have driven a
wedge into our relationship
because they're so bad the problems in
that's why you've seen that happening by
the way how much how much are you seeing
that in marriages right now families run
up friendships
friendships getting destroyed certainly
identity politics doesn't help uh
that destroys a lot of relationships as
well but the problems in california
bring those identities out
yeah so lots of relationships pat i
think if you came back to california for
a month and you spent there i think the
one thing that you would notice is
they've gotten rid of glamour glamour
used to define california it used to be
something
that drawed people in it was glamorous
the dream la the lifestyle hollywood the
the way hollywood is being run right now
it is completely destroyed glamour you
drive through the streets of west
hollywood you feel depressed
you see the advertisements on the
billboards now it's all negative content
it's stuff you don't want to watch
that's not california that's america man
there's no more heroes it was all
different you know it always had that
gleaming thing that people wanted to go
to
and it's just they've gotten rid of
glamour and that's really depressing and
that's why i said sultan sjk
who gave 500 who moved here from new
york city if you want to apply for a job
uh send us an email text us at
310-340-1132-310-340-1132 we will
schedule an interview
with you kevin final thoughts california
how do you envision this thing taking
place over the next what's the timeline
with the recall right now how much time
do we got
we've got probably uh either the first
week uh first
second week of september through the
first week of november that's that's our
range for when the election is which
makes it really hard to campaign to
figure out when you want to do your
rallies and
uh but uh yeah look the the issue that a
lot of californians don't understand
right now is the recall is one ballot
now a lot of folks right now believe
okay i'll vote on the recall and if
gavin's recall
then i'll look at the backup options it
doesn't work that way you get one ballot
should you have a nissan be recalled yes
or no pick your backup
it's on one ballot and so if california
wants those 20 changes
especially the top five which are the
number one priority for your number one
solving homelessness
traffic community policing uh and our
future schools right the other issues
that we've talked about
then then california should vote yes on
that recall and vote yes on meet kevin
papras for governor go to meet kevin.com
to support
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye